today I want to tell you about a
pressing social issue now it's not
nuclear arm it's not immigration and
it's not malaria I'm here to talk about
movies now in all seriousness movies are
actually really important in film we can
be wildly entertained and we can also be
transported through storytelling
storytelling is so important stories
tell us what society's value they offer
us lessons and they share and preserve
our history stories are amazing but
stories don't give everyone the same
opportunity to appear within them
particularly not stories
compartmentalized in the form of
American movies in film interestingly
enough females are still erased and
marginalized in a lot of our stories and
I learned this for the first time about
ten years ago when I did my first study
on gender role and g-rated films since
then we've conducted more than 30
investigations my team is tired and and
I've committed my life as researcher and
activists to fighting the inclusion
crisis in Hollywood so today what I'd
like to do is tell you about that crisis
I want to talk about gender inequality
in film I want to tell you how it is
perpetuated and then I'm going to tell
you how we're going to fix it however
one caveat before I begin my data are
really depressing so I want to apologize
in advance because I'm going to put you
all in a really bad mood but I'm going
to bring it up at the end and I'm going
to present a silver lining to fix this
mess that we've been in for a very very
long time
so let's start with the gravity of the
situation each year my research team
examines the top 100 grossing films in
the United States what we do is we look
at every speaking or named character on
screen now to account in one of my
investigations all a character has to do
is say one word this is a very low bar
thus far we've looked at 800 movies from
2007 to 2015
cataloguing every speaking character on
screen for gender race/ethnicity LGBTQ
and characters with a disability let's
take a look it's really some problematic
trends first females are still
noticeably absent on screen and film
across eight hundred movies and thirty
five thousand two hundred and five
speaking characters less than a third of
all roles go to girls and women less
than a third there's been no change from
2007 to 2015 and if you compare our
results to a small sample of films from
1946 to 1955 there's been no change in
over a half of a century over half a
century but we're half of the population
now if we look at this data
intersectionally which has been a focus
of today the picture becomes even more
problematic across the top 100 films of
just last year forty-eight films didn't
feature one black or african-american
speaking character not one 70 films were
devoid of Asian or Asian American
speaking characters that were girls or
women none 84 films didn't feature one
female character that had a disability
in 93 were devoid of lesbians bisexual
or transgender female speaking
characters this is not under
representation this is your ratio and I
call this the epidemic of invisibility
now when we move from prevalence to
protagonists the story is still
problematic out of a hundred films last
year only 32 featured a female lead or
co-lead driving the action only three
out
100 films featured an underrepresented
female driving the story and only one
diverse woman that was 45 years of age
or older at the time of theatrical
release now let's look at portrayal in
addition to the numbers you just saw
females are far more likely to be
sexualized in film than their male
counterparts matter of fact they're
about three times as likely to be shown
a sexually revealing clothing partially
naked and they're far more likely to be
thin now sometimes in animation females
are so thin that their wee size
approximates the circumference of their
upper arm we like to say that these gals
have no room for a womb or any other
internal organ now all joking aside
theory suggests research confirms
exposure to thin ideals and objectifying
content can lead to body dissatisfaction
internalization of the thin ideal and
self objectification among some female
viewers obviously what we see on screen
and what we see in the world they do not
match they do not match matter of fact
if we lived in the screen world we would
have a population crisis on our hands so
as soon as I recognize these patterns I
want to find out why and it turns out
that there are two drivers to inequality
on screen content creator gender and
misperceptions of the audience let's
unpack them really quick if you want to
changing into patterns I just talked
about all you have to do is hire female
directors turns out the female directors
are associated with in terms of short
films and indie indie films more girls
and women on screen more stories with
women in the center more stories with
women 40 years of age or older on screen
which i think is good news for this
crowd more underrepresented sorry uh not
sorry but not sorry more
underrepresented characters in terms of
race and ethnicity and most importantly
more women working behind the camera in
key production roles easy answer to the
problem that we just talked about
or is it it's actually not 800 films
2007 to 2015
886 directors only 4.1 percent are women
only 3 or african-american or black and
only one woman was Asian
so why is it so difficult to have female
directors if they're part of the
solution well to answer this question we
conducted a study we interviewed dozens
of industry insiders and ask them about
directors turns out both male and female
executives when they think director they
think male they perceive the traits of
leadership to be masculine in nature so
when they're going to hire a director to
command a crew leadership be a visionary
or be General Patton all the things that
we've heard their thoughts in ideations
pull male the perception of director or
a leader is inconsistent with the
perception of a woman the roles are in
congruous which is consistent with a lot
of research in the psychological arena
second factor contributing to inequality
on screen is misperceptions of the
audience I don't need to tell this crowd
50% of the people that go to the box
office and buy tickets are girls and
women in this country right but we're
not perceived to be a viable or
financially lucrative target audience
further there are some misperceptions
about whether females can open a film
open a film means if you place a female
at the center it doesn't have the return
on investment that if you place a male
at the center of a story does this
misperception is actually costly right
especially in the wake of franchise
successes like The Hunger Games
pitch-perfect where that small little
indie film star wars the force awakens
our own economic analyses show that
gender of the lead character doesn't
play a role in economic success in the
United States but what does production
costs alone or in conjunction with how
widely a film is distributed in this
country it's not the gender of the lead
character so at this point we should all
be sufficiently depressed no change in
50 years few female directors working
behind the camera and the entertainment
industry does not trust us as an
audience well I told you there would be
a silver lining and there is there are
actually simple and tangible solutions
to fixing this problem that involve
content creators executives and
consumers like the individuals in this
room let's talk about a few of them the
first is what I call just add five did
you know if we looked at the top 100
films next year and simply added five
female speaking characters on screen to
each of those films it would create a
new norm if we were to do this for three
contiguous years we would be at gender
parity for the first time and over a
half of a century now this approach is
advantageous for a variety of reasons
one it doesn't take away jobs for male
actors heaven forbid
- it's actually cost-effective it
doesn't cost that much three ability
pipeline for talent and four it
humanizes the production process why
because it makes sure that there's women
on set second solution is for a-list
talent a listers as we all know can make
demands in their contracts particularly
the ones that work on the biggest
Hollywood films what if those a listers
simply added an equity clause or an
inclusion writer into their contract now
what does that mean well you probably
don't know but the typical feature film
has about forty to forty five speaking
characters in it I would argue that only
eight to ten of those characters are
actually relevant to this story except
neighbor Avengers write a few more and
Avengers the remaining thirty are still
rules there's no reason why those minor
roles can't match or reflect the
demography of where the story is taken
taking place an equity writer by an
a-lister in their contract can stipulate
that those roles reflect the world in
which we actually live now there's no
reason why a network a studio or a
production company cannot adopt the same
contractual language in their
negotiation processes third solution
this would be for the entertainment
industry Hollywood in particular to
adopt the Rooney rule when it comes to
hiring practices around directors now in
the NFL the Rooney rule stipulates that
if a team wants to hire a coach from
outside the organization what they have
to do is interview an underrepresented
candidate the exact same principle can
apply to Hollywood films how well on
these top films executives and agents
can make sure that women and people of
color are not only on the consideration
list but they're actually interviewed
for the job now one might say why is
this important because it exposes or
introduces executives to female
directors
who otherwise fall prey to exclusionary
hiring practices the fourth solution is
for consumers like me and you if we want
to see more films by for and about women
we have to support them
it may mean going to the independent
theater chain instead of the multiplex
or it might mean scrolling down a little
further online to find a film by a
female director or it may be writing a
check in funding a film particularly by
a female director from an
underrepresented background right we
need to write call and email companies
that are making and distributing films
and we need to post on our social media
accounts when we want to see inclusive
representation women on screen and most
importantly women behind the camera we
need to make our voices heard and our
dollars count now we actually have the
ability to change the world on this one
the US and its content films in
particular have captured the
imaginations of audiences worldwide
worldwide so that means that the film
industry has unprecedented access to be
able to distribute stories about
equality all around the world imagine
what would happen if the film industry
aligned its values with what it shows on
screen it could foster inclusion and
acceptance for girls and women people of
color the LGBT community individuals
with disability and so many more on
around the world the only thing that the
film industry has to do is unleash its
secret weapon and that storytelling now
at the beginning of this talk I said
that films that they can actually
transport us but I would like to argue
that films they can transform us none of
us in this room
have grown up or experienced a
storytelling landscape with fully
realized female characters none of us
because the numbers haven't changed what
would happen if the next generation of
audiences grew up with a whole different
screen reality what would happen well
I'm here to tell you today that's not
only possible to change what we see on
screen but I am impatient for it to get
here so let's agree to take action today
to eradicate the epidemic of
invisibility and let's agree to take
action today to agree that US audiences
and global viewers demand and deserve
more and let's agree today that the next
generation of viewers and audiences that
they deserve to see the stories we were
never able to see thank you
[Applause]